[Music]
[Music]
- hey everyone welcome to simulation we
are now sitting down with arena Cronin
hello hi thank you for joining us on the
show thank you for having me yeah I'm
excited there's gonna be a lot of fun
we're gonna be talking about the AI
century we're we talking about how all
these different technologies are kind of
coalescing together how they're
impacting business how we got to advise
and strategize businesses to get ready
for this this new century arv are
autonomous vehicles machine learning
facial recognition robots all of this
stuff yeah and you have a great
background in this and now we're about
to dive into it what do you want to know
let's do it
so what why even in the first place cuz
let's so we have spout reality two years
doing that and that's consulting with AR
VR yes and now you're with shell Israel
a transformation group shout out to
shells have been on over on our show
before he's a good guy
fun fun conversation we had as well so
now and now you're doing advising in all
those other fields as well so what kind
of led you to the realization that
businesses really need to get ready for
this upcoming technology boom and how
are you helping them I think it all
comes down to visual transformation
so over the last five years or so it's
become really clear that video is like
becoming more and more important of
course people are still writing and
reading books and reporters and that
kind of thing but in terms of like
YouTube and Facebook and just all kinds
of visual happenings right so what's the
new thing then with visual it's for to
become as three-dimensional as possible
so you want it to come as true to life
mm-hmm and I think that's where the push
came for Facebook where they realized
hey so things are really getting visual
here and they could tell because the
metrics are like off the charts when
they introduce video for it to happen
so the next thing has to be then
something that is more realistic and
what is that that's more like 3d I think
that's why they really started why they
actually got it oculus for sure and so
they have this bet that and it's not
only the MS HTC vive and it's the whole
ecosystem for virtual reality so I think
the whole thing started from me in
realizing first of all I'm more visual
than I am I love literature but like the
visual stuff really grabs me so the idea
of actually having something realistic
in front of me that's a simulation
that's not real and yet I can
emotionally connect to it and somehow
then I become part of that simulation
and then it's real for me I think
doesn't only capture my imagination but
now more and more the population out
there is realizing that there really is
something to virtual reality that's
where it started with me that you asked
about other things like augmented
reality it's the next step where you're
mixing
those you know characters that are
virtual like in your regular world -
there's more flexibility there there's
more things that can happen with
augmented reality in terms of business
being able to use that for selling
things for retail for also entertainment
so it's a little wider than a virtual
reality but it's long the same kind of
lines of creating a different world and
here it's kind of a mixed world of where
and it's fun also so it's not only all
about dollars and then we have
artificial intelligence that brings in
language as well so with machine
learning we have basically computer
programming and systems trying to
understand patterns that are out there
in the real world so both on an
illiterate kind of way trying to get
patterns for speech when you when they
do BOTS chat BOTS that are using
artificial intelligence now and then you
move to the visual understanding video
understanding photographs trying to get
patterns in that and it all kind of
comes together to me both the kind of
like augmented sense of things where now
you're gonna actually introduce
artificial intelligence with machine
learning when you when you speak you can
match things and then you could have the
3d visualization called up and the
artificial intelligence can understand
what you're saying and call up the 3d
visual so it kind of all comes together
that's one way of looking at why I'm
kind of fascinated by this kind of
reality that you could create yeah
I like how you guided us through the
transition from books and then audio to
then video and now from two-dimensional
video to the three-dimensional which is
now the AR and VR experiences that we're
having and then and the simulations that
come from that and the and that's across
so many different industries that can
leverage simulations from biotech to
robotics there's so many different ways
to do that and then the ability to find
patterns in this data and figure out how
to make this applicable to us so it's
totally makes sense and you see I like
the way that you talk about in a very
story format I think it's really
relatable for people because of that so
you've been now communicating this to
businesses and getting them to be like
aha
we need to do something in the AI or the
machine learning or the AR and VR space
we need to do something there almost
everybody does don't they need to do
something yeah I think okay so when you
think about advertising just the the
long arc of how they came about that was
basically text with some photographs
right and the impact for that kind of
visual that you'e got isn't very high
unless it's something really close to
you and then that's going to be a small
population out there that could really
access
emotional feelings for text and a
photograph or a couple photographs so
once you bring dimensionality to it the
three dimensionality and then when it's
personalized for you by speech by
artificial intelligence
and when you're when you're saying
something and some artificial being
can't understand what you're saying and
actually provides you with information
that you need and then you combine that
with a visual as well I think that is
the future for retail at least and then
for all kinds of other businesses also
for medicine for visuals for surgeons
that need to pull up a visual right away
and then use their voice to be able to
figure out how to move that thing or you
know so if there's there's there's so
many different industries and areas
where you could take
three-dimensionality along with
artificial intelligence to manipulate
that three dimensionality that has an
impact and you listed the doctor example
with the surgeon then there's the
current use of in the construction space
as well there's so many different uses I
mean we can go off and off about every
industry and how they're trying to
figure out how to use this I like how
you said that it brings us closer to did
you say the real like it's a reality to
the way that we live in our own like
three dimensional world the closer we
can get to that kind of an experience
where I could maybe even feel what
someone else is feeling or get into
their world or be able to see their
whole physical entity rather than maybe
just the words on a book yeah yeah I
mean okay so the next step beyond this
is not only emotional feeling but haptic
feeling mm-hmm which is where when you
see something that initially you realize
isn't real but you kind of buy into it
because it's done so well and I'm
talking about both virtual reality and
augmented reality
where you could actually sense this
artificial boundary or material so that
it brings it really you can actually
believe even more that what you're
living through is something real so
again right now a lot of the cinematic
VR and entertainment people are talking
about how the impact of VR is on their
emotions because it kind of brings you
into the picture a little more but it's
not only emotional I mean if you think
about location-based entertainment and
company called the void which had the
Ghostbusters experience in New York in
Utah they have this amazing building
where now they're working on a 45 minute
experience that you could live through
with six of your friends yeah and and
play games and have a narrative so it's
like the new movie basically the
immersive experience design yeah yeah
and it has different arcs of narrative
so depending on what you say it'll get
it'll take you into a different story
yes that is the future so not only with
entertainment but with all kinds of
different things so again we were
talking about advertising the old form
of advertising how about that flatness
and the non dimensionality advertising
now turns into something that can take
you further in your inquiry so you had a
question about I don't know you want to
find new drapes or something really
boring like that so you you go about
that and then you talk about new living
space and then it brings you someplace
else and it's like brings you out of the
initial question that you have into all
kinds of different areas that you didn't
think you would go into because of the
smart AI that is asking you and feeding
you things and then visualizing it for
you
I like how you said that haptics was
this other integration being able to
feel physically as well what's going on
if there's so many body suits now and
we're seeing this iteration sue what
what I guess what even comes after I
wanna I want to touch on a couple of
things you said but yeah and now I'm
very interested in in to see if you know
what's coming after this body suit like
well how can we actually get the
physical feeling without having to be
wearing a full-body suit okay so there
are many experiments by Disney and by a
couple of other companies they haven't
gone all the way through because it
takes kind of a lot of power in the
particular environment that you're in
but there's like wind bursts of wind
that are so strong that actually have
friction that make it feel like
something you're actually touching
something cool and there's all kinds of
other systems that are set up that are
electrical base that will also give you
the same kind of artificial it's
artificially based obviously but it
makes it'll make you feel like there is
some yeah object there yeah that is
giving so let's say you're you're
throwing an imaginary ball so you'll
feel like the different fluctuations of
the ball basically depending you know if
it's a softer ball or whatever it would
allow you to feel that so I'm not sure
about the bodysuit being the way to go I
think it's kind of been a little bit too
invasive for me mm-hmm
because it's obviously you have to put
it on you are still aware no matter what
that you have something on your body the
best way would be that it's coming from
the exterior environment and depending
on
the appendage that you are sensing with
you know if it's with your fingers or
your arm then it'll actually have direct
application there versus hitting it here
that kind of thing and also they've done
it you know lots of theatrical things
with smells and like rain and sound and
stuff like that yeah that's good yeah
sound is really important what about
pervy AR AR where are we and we'll get
to immersive experience design I want to
talk about that after but with VR AR
again doesn't it seem a little bit uh -
would you call it - I said invasive
invasive doesn't it seem like it's a
little when you have it completely
covering your eyes and you're strapped
in with a bunch of cords and or versus
when you're even just wearing the AR
headset and walking around wherever you
go
doesn't it still seem like you're
wearing a computer on your face and it's
still invasive in that sense and where
are we going after that what are the
next iterations yeah okay so the best
experiences that I've ever watched let's
start with virtual reality even if it
was a heavier headset I'm not gonna go
into which what's the heavier headset is
depending on the quality of the
experience that I was watching in terms
of the colors and the immersiveness and
the pics not not having pixelization and
also not having the lagging when you're
moving around if that stuff is really
high quality I forget that I have the
headset on mm-hmm
sometimes you feel it around your ears
you know and they put the head the for
the sound to block out the sound or to
actually create bigger sound depending
on what you're doing that's kind of
cumbersome and in the future what
they're doing is they're coming out with
headsets that have that built in to the
extent where it might even be better
than having an external system on your
ears
in terms of headsets now for the future
okay so I'm hoping and I think that
future virtual reality experiences are
going to keep getting more and more
quality okay
so that I will forget that is almost
forget that it's a virtual reality
experience I'm in what would that look
like um the best of them are interactive
so that first of all I'm able to move
around in a space I'm not sitting in a
chair I'm not swiveling around in a
chair and I don't have a small space I'm
able to to go quite a distance yeah yeah
it's a football field inside it could be
yeah with with the location-based
experiences they've done these
experiments where it could be a pretty
actually not such a big room but the way
that they've rigged it up you actually
do feel like you're walking straight a
long distance and in fact you've been
walking around pretty much in a circle
they are able to do that depending on
the level of the flooring so they're
experimenting with all this kind of
stuff but even if you are having a wire
if you have a wireless headset and
you're half-sphere achill yeah you can
walk in but no no I'm talking about
bigger yeah yeah even even bigger what
if they're not pods they're they're just
they're like theatrical sets where they
have you walking and you're just like a
like eight feet by eight feet or
something isn't it it's bigger it's like
100 feet yeah but it's from the Lindon
Utah d'void headquarters for the
original Ghostbusters experience there
they had you going up in an elevator
it's called like the omni wheel right
the one that I was thinking of yeah
there's a couple of you I'm not really
into that I'm more yeah yeah roaming I
wouldn't run it totally straps you in
verses like yeah yeah so the best
experiences are gonna be the ones that
allow you to go as far as possible so
you won't even have to go around on the
circle but you will be able to
wirelessly take your headset and go as
far as you can
or feel like you're going really far
interact with other people that you've
come into the experience with talk with
them talk to characters that actually
don't exist mm-hmm exactly like you
don't know it's your you think it's your
friend actually hey no it's character
that's there talking to you that's an AI
character that depending on what you say
to them will take you into a new
narrative yep so and also the narratives
are longer you know they'll end up being
an hour long you'll be able to do this
kind of stuff they pick your own journey
that's what you're talking about with
the immersive experience design as well
so you think that we're moving towards
the wireless connectivity which is for
sure we know a couple companies that are
working on the wireless connectivity
then we're also moving to these larger
spaces then we're also moving to either
people that are also playing in the game
or artificial avatars that are playing
in the game that you interact with and
then as you engage with the environment
and with these different avatars then
the experience design changes as you go
through it in the way that you've
interacted with it and that has also
very directly linked with the immersive
experience design that you mentioned
earlier and we wanted a touch on this
and now these two stories can kind of
merge which is theirs now what is it
called like wolf something wolf Bay oh I
forgot it's called in there's one and uh
I think Santa Fe called wolf something
or no maybe I'm wrong there's one that's
an immersive experience at Santa Fe
that's called wolf something and that
one is like 15 bucks or something that
you can run in there and do whatever you
want throw me a loaf me el wolf maybe
yeah yeah yeah but okay so that's not it
they're different of course yeah yeah
doesn't I don't even know for me Alan
wolf has any VR or not and I know that
you said the one in Utah yeah as VR and
yeah so now you're walking into these
immersive experiences and then you
have the VR or not option and then if
you do the VR option then it's okay
great now you can do that whole story
like we said or the non VR option you
can go to different sets that that you
interact with or maybe you wear a are
throughout argument agree throughout it
so it seems like these immersive
experience designs though whether it be
in without a are or what they are or
with VR are the sort of ways that we're
gonna be like playing and engaging with
each other and they'll help a lot with
location agnosticism to I thought that
it was also very interesting to know to
be able to work with other people on a
project no matter where you are or to be
able to go and travel to a different
place in the world no matter where you
are so for business especially being
able to interact with people no matter
where they are I mean obviously they do
this now on teleconference saying
whatever it's not that great you see the
people's faces you hear them talking a
lot of the times things get done but
it's really not intimate you really
don't get closer with the people that
you're working with but you know you
have to do it for work so you do it
anyway so however if you if you were
able to have an augmented reality
workspace so that if possible the work
with the person you're working with is
actually right in front of you this
somehow brings it closer I mean it could
be is the way I'm looking at you now and
this it would be the same basically
eight thousands of miles away from yes
and then being able to demonstrate oh
let's turn on the video now to talk
about you know to be able to work on the
project it really adds something so it's
so much better outside dimensionality
and I think it's a huge business
everybody is wanted this since science
fiction time great when you have the
telephones that had the the video on it
that was like a big deal now we finally
have that
now that's not enough because it isn't
when I have somebody that looks like
they're real here talking and being able
to do business yeah at meetings let's
say you have to usually be at a location
and meeting and you'd rather have your
avatar there and you could look
whichever way you want you could be at
home in your shorts or whatever but your
avatar is at the meeting and your
director you're talking and you're at
the meeting so I mean there's a lot of
benefits not every fantastic naked and
be going to my business meetings in a
suit in a while yeah oh you thing is
okay so everybody wants to be as
comfortable as possible they want to
reach this nirvana where you're you're
at your business best but you're also
enjoying it
that's the Nirvana that everybody wants
it's real women that's heels right you
don't want to wear heels but you want to
appear that you're wearing heels that is
a really good point
you why why would you actually have to
wear them if you can wear you know and
then you could have like dozens or
hundreds of different styles and you
don't actually own them Oh even better
dematerialize ourselves I'm so excited
for dematerialization and so over it I
hope and I feel like a lot of the
younger kids also are getting more and
more over it it's also fantasy so
there's an aspect of fun that's involved
with that too it's not all you know hey
this is all drudgery and we got a
somehow put it together yeah that's like
let's experiment and see what kind of
it's almost it's almost artistic
depending on the temperament that
someone has they can create great art
being different selves all the time okay
so we were talking about progression
like where is this gonna go into the
headset you said perhaps is on you know
it doesn't feel so great it's heavy
you're aware of it no I'm saying and
future with good quality experiences yes
you'll still be aware that it's there
but then the headsets are getting
lighter like your glasses should be
fantastic yes and then a contact lens
the neural lace and then it's over
well singularity there was something
that Intel was actually working on until
very recently called the want and
thought yeah they were glasses that
looked a lot like this actually looked
like a pair that I still have at home
and they were lighter than that pair and
they just discontinued it was augmented
reality where you actually read text on
your glasses it was so clear I have no
idea why they stopped it but I think the
future for both virtual reality and
augmented reality okay there are some
limitations with virtual reality because
you do have to be closed off yet right
but there's something that could be
developed that sure you could just then
strip away and then you have augmented
reality great there's no reason why
you'd have to have something really
happy I think's keep getting as the
progression goes along tech technically
speaking smaller and the controllers get
better and better and it gets all
wireless services that's where it's
going and then you have artificial
intelligence and they're guiding you
through the narrative or showing you
things that you're interested in so it
all kind of works together and the new
computer is in the glasses basically yep
yeah so that's a good walk through on
the AR VR and makes reality side of
things on the immersive experience
design side of things so that was a
pretty good walk through there's so much
to unpack and that's only just the
beginning but how about we jump a little
boat over to how businesses are starting
to apply or how how even people are
starting to get ready for what's gonna
happen with autonomous vehicles and
there's so many other ones of these
categories that we should talk about
with facial recognition of machine
learning in that sense how that applies
of course they are but also so many
other aspects like China which is very
interesting this authoritarian police
state in the way that they facially
recognize who's doing what what we're
trying to get you but let's be careful
well there is something that China is
doing now that I think in the u.s.
probably won't fly at least for a while
so basically if you jaywalk
they'll have they have facial
recognition and within 30 seconds of you
jaywalking you have a ticket on your
phone yeah through each other yeah you
know somebody got beat up for jaywalking
we're not talking about physical stuff
is gonna happen for decades and
centuries and has been for hundreds of
thousands of years we're talking about
the morphing of something that is
actually physical and that's now digital
and can have almost the same amount of
force not it maybe even more to get
people in trouble and have more impact
on people's lives as a results without
physical education well it could lead to
physical altercations but like I I'm
sure that some of the people that are
caught by China end up getting beat up
there are just certain things like you
said that aren't gonna fly in the u.s.
at least for a little while but then but
then they will fly in the u.s. because
big-money interests will likely surpass
what small people can
try and say we'll work for their
democracy or their data privacy and
rights we'll see maybe that won't happen
who knows but from what we're seeing
right now in China it's very much so
moving forward quickly with things that
they want to get done with a one-party
system just top down push it down make
it happen
is faster than a gridlock the United
States political system that's why we
rely on the private sector to make
innovation now so I think that that's
also very interesting to analyze which
is a point to what ron was saying we are
a very global project simulation is a
very global project we feature lots of
different people from around the world
and and we speak about China in a way
that is like here's some fantastic
things about China here's some not same
thing with the US US has fantastic
things and then it doesn't as well so
where exactly we're going with the
technology of facial recognition can be
a little bit scary at times I don't know
how closely I'm already being monitored
by my cell phone in my laptop and all my
social accounts it's likely very very
closely already monitored and there's no
way to get off the grid unless you
completely unplug and move but it can
get to a point where it's absolutely
impossible to get off of the grid and
then we're like in an oh no what okay so
I think privately we're already there
it's just publicly people aren't aware
so for example in the UK a lot of places
streets in inside restaurants you could
see from the street into the restaurants
and into your apartment and that kind of
stuff CCTV mm-hm
pretty much records everything and
that's that's for anti you know
anti-criminal basically so you could
catch criminals you could prevent crime
that kind of thing and it's accepted by
the population of the UK for obvious
reasons because it works and UK also
you know policemen don't carry on guns
so it's a different kind of culture
what's happening I think with privacy
and this is all tied up with AI and
facial recognition and scanning and all
that kind of thing I mean the government
already does this stuff for national
security right it's just that the pub it
doesn't in the US and in other countries
many of the countries in Europe that are
more privacy into privacy they won't
take something like this and use it for
other social things in a public level so
in China for example you have a social
reading
yeah the sesame credit it's so
fascinating right but that's all tied in
with monitoring your actions yeah how do
they monitor the actions it's through
artificial intelligence machine through
a computer facial recognition and then
through digitalization of what you do
with your bank and you know you travel
so it's like this whole ecosystem of
trailing you what you which you're how
you live for good citizen credit or bad
citizen credit and then being able to be
limited or opened up based on how you
act so I don't think unless something
really goes wrong in the u.s. that this
will be instituted here I mean it's it's
instituted in some very non it's it's
certainly some kids think that that's
the way to go if they do scoring you
know in terms of how many Facebook
friends you have and all that kind of
thing like black mirror stuff but in
terms of an official government stance
of how this should be rolled out to the
public I don't think that's going to
happen
yeah yeah we are it's a that's probably
one of the most interesting
conversations that we should be having
is how we're gonna design the social
aspect the social fabric of civilization
in all of its nuance because we didn't
even talk about how that affects health
care and education and energy use we
talk more about how that affects our our
our what would seen on video cameras
about what we're doing and and the data
that's being processed through WeChat or
Facebook or whatever the social platform
is so it's this is this is probably one
of the most important conversations to
have about civilization design is how
are we going to make happen may we may
as well get there I mean we didn't touch
on autonomous vehicles and robotics too
much along the way but we're kind of
already talking about this point so why
don't we why don't we finish on that
point and then we'll come back to the
autonomous vehicles in a robot yeah
definitely get to that um I just want to
mention a study that was recently
published you know all of the spaces the
businesses have right now non office
space but rather that it's open space
everybody who works in an open space you
know the Apple the new Apple building
that kind of thing so of course you have
people in academic settings that are
thinking like how does this affect
society do people work better when
they're working in these open spaces how
do women feel in a gender kind of
environment being always out of the open
so I'm not saying that this is exactly
the end-all study for this but it was
just published and it says that women
that work in these open spaces feel more
like they're on show so they worry about
how they look more so it makes them more
gendered so they're all they like
dressed better they did you know they
followed people around for many months
to see how they reacted and so they're
very they're more worried about how they
look what their hair looks like all that
kind of stuff
and it actually dampens their their work
yeah it makes them more self-conscious
so when you and I wouldn't even say it's
only women but they focus on women here
it's gotta be everybody it's always a
little bit more worried about how things
appear how people are looking at them do
they see do they hear when I'm talking
when I'm on the phone talking to
somebody that kind of thing so it's that
kind of Big Brother
everybody's watching that is tied into
this idea of you know artificial
intelligence and monitoring and all that
kind of stuff I think society is going
in this direction where the monitoring
of everything is gonna happen in
different degree differing degrees in in
countries depending on whatever their
culture is but it's moving I think
everybody is moving to that model where
everything's more out in the open
there's less privacy and there's more of
this trying to fit in yeah yeah part of
that has me thinking about what we were
talking about earlier if they are at VR
and how location agnosticism will
actually make it totally cool for me to
just be wherever I want looking however
I want to look without actually at home
needing to look that way yeah I like
that aspect of it let's are wrong
soundbite but that's our journey it's
all good that's our 15 minutes Oh Tommy
okay so we got to go into autonomous
vehicles yeah let's do it all right so
um obviously there there are a lot of
issues with autonomous vehicles but
there is good news that a lot of the
companies that are working on this type
of technology are using artificial
intelligence and
I wouldn't say machine learnt mission
learning will come in and another after
after they figure out the visuals so the
visualization instead of having a car
out there
trying to figure out all the roads
getting into accidents and that kind of
thing they run these scenarios these
simulations that are driven by
artificial intelligence neural nets and
all kinds of other algorithms that that
are set up and they run through you know
potential accident situations and all
kinds of things so that the the
autonomous vehicle AI learns without
actually physically going through any of
this and I remember at a recent
conference at the game developer
conference uber was there I was like
woody what are you guys doing here oh
they're hiring thousands of people to
develop these simulations for the
autonomous vehicles so it's a huge thing
and I think they're gonna be bumps along
the road but I'm still on the road but I
think it I think that it will happen
because we're dealing with computer
power and simulations are not difficult
to do and as we come you more and more
sophisticated it's gonna get it right
yeah and with robotics what do you want
to know about robotics robotics isn't
just like AR VR is just [ __ ]
everywhere it's so difficult to hone in
on something about it just a quick touch
on autonomous vehicles I like how you
said that they're running the
simulations right now yeah because that
saves them the the learning comes in the
computer training environment rather
than the real world but then when they
get out in the real world they stuff to
perform and continuously observe their
environment and learn there's so much
interest in that field it's I mean
I'm just just thinking about the solar
power roof charging your car and then
going and driving your car somewhere and
then you're parking your car and then
your car going and making you money
because you're don't need to use it
during that time and it's just such an
interesting and like smart contracts
between the person that's renting your
car and it's just like it's getting
ridiculous these are all a completely
new things that just came out in the
last couple of years and they're all
over people's brains and and and I and I
wonder what the difference is between
someone here and the Midwest of the u.s.
in terms of knowing about this and then
what's the difference between someone
here and someone in I don't know rural
Vietnam like knowing about this like
just I just like I just I just wonder
where people's minds are and what's
gonna happen with all these technologies
proliferating and how it's gonna affect
children and how it's gonna affect
wealth inequality so maybe that's what
we talked about just end it off with
robotics with robots there seem to be
again across every single industry over
robota sizing things is very fascinating
apparently that's what happened at the
Tesla factory over robota sizing things
still having humans in the equation and
that seems to be what the trajectory is
going to be like this hybridizing of AI
and robotics with with humans where are
some of your favorite examples of
robotics being used today and what are
you most looking forward to with robots
in the future besides sex robots okay
[Laughter]
trouble young man you better knock off
you [ __ ] you have some respect
however it isn't an area that it's not
built up in yet that is my favorite I
want to have robots in the home doing
what I want them I would okay so it'd be
great if I even had a robot as a friend
I mean I don't have issues with us some
people do they think it's uncanny and
weird
but I think the closer a robot gets to
being human like the more easy it is for
someone to see a this being can be
interesting to me you know so not only
for you know manual chores are the
obvious thing right
which Amazon is reportedly working on
bought a robot in a home to to cook to
do whatever but I mean people are
already talking to these like spheres
asking for Mason right might as well
like okay Google transformation group do
exactly
so why what what sorry I missed all that
what did you say my acumen also
mentioned she wants a robot as a friend
a dog oh oh and remember we had been on
the show and bina is literally a flesh
vehicle with a bunch of robotic gears
inside of it and natural language
processing so yeah and literally just
sit on your table right there and and
talk to you here's your spirit okay
Google Barack Obama's age see that then
it'll actually work but I mean why
wouldn't you want to have this embodied
and have something a little more
intelligent and that you could talk
about film 1950 film noir with I have a
real conversation and have it look at
your eyes and have it move its mouth
talks and engage you and engage your
mood maybe emotionally it's really
important for you to talk to it okay so
that's interesting you picked home robot
yeah yeah I obviously business I mean
the robotics for business isn't going on
for a very long time yeah all right but
I mean it's gonna for restaurants for
coffee shops they're not gonna be people
there anymore they're gonna be making
this stuff I mean how hard is it to make
this food that is being made in a
freakin diner really freaking easy yeah
so I mean it's actually going to the
those jobs people worry about jobs being
taken over by robots and I understand
that but the job that a cook has in a
diner that kind of job he can have
another job that he's able to use skills
on that level doesn't have to be working
in a diner so I believe that jobs will
be created different types of digital
you know in the digital age you have
different types of jobs that that will
come on many different levels from a
lower level that you don't need to have
a PhD to do something to a higher level
so I'm not too worried about robots
taking over jobs there'll be new jobs
for sure but there will be a lot of jobs
lost and people need to be retrained
different types of the jobs that are out
there those types will start to change
but this has been happening for a lever
yeah Industrial Revolution the types of
jobs have changed definitely yeah it's
it's it's still really important to keep
in mind that the amount of jobs that are
gonna be displaced right away it's gonna
be I think much greater than the amount
of jobs that are gonna be available plus
people will really have to want to get
retrained and it's difficult to want to
get people motivated to get retrained
for work this is the thing now I don't
think this is gonna happen like
lightning fast everybody's worried about
this because they're like millions of
people are not gonna have jobs yeah in
ten years though ten years for this this
thing to happen like everywhere in all
the industries sure but three million
jobs is just for driving email for sure
be ten years for driving yeah
that's three million what are you
talking about like taxicabs trucks okay
movers and lyft drivers this to me is a
skill like a lower ended skill people
who do that have other skills that they
could work and you know yeah but those
three million jobs that are gonna
disappear or not just gonna reappear but
I I agree that there will be people that
will have to work with
in that hybrid position of figuring out
how the autonomous vehicle will work on
the streets and that there's so many
jobs opening up in that sector and I'm
like I really don't think that this is
going to happen like I said over 10
years I do think that it's it's a
process because as you're saying with
Elon Musk you know he overdid the robot
ization of his Tesla factory we don't
know
yeah China has like 50 electric car
companies now and I'm just I'm just
saying that even though we think that
ten years it's not gonna happen I'm just
saying that it's likely gonna happen in
ten years for the autonomous vehicles
yes okay yeah okay that's three million
here and I think it's like 20 million or
something around the world okay so do
you remember the song by Cyndi Lauper
there's a hole in my heart it goes all
the way to China do you remember that
song no all right never mind go back to
the show I'm sorry there's a hole in my
heart it goes all the way to China what
yeah I just want to make sure that was
soon yeah yeah yeah it was all right
last call sorry yeah but last point
you're good she's she's around for a
little bit joke around all right
last point is okay we have globalisation
and wealth inequality that are kind of
peering into our world right now where
how are we gonna work together across
all these borders and how are we gonna
make sure that the classes don't just
break into two with the ultra rich and
ultra poor okay so I tend to be a
realist on these type of issues I don't
think that most countries are for a long
time gonna really work together to fix
this problem I think that there is
something happening
not only in the United States but in
Europe and people are understanding that
it's happening but just like with
climate change it's like all this stuff
is happening and the action isn't being
taken it's gonna take a while for some
coordination to happen and it might not
happen until maybe something really bad
like an extreme let's hope not but yeah
I really don't but by virtue of their
being different countries that have very
different cultures and economies this is
already kind of like a boundary it's a
problem yeah it's definitely how can we
work together to prevent a massive
nationalistic I Pro only my people type
push ok so I know that which shell and a
number of people in the 2000s we're
talking about social media being a power
and bringing people together to change
things I think that that possibility is
still there I think what we've scrapped
we've scratched the surface on social
media it's become a very big kind of
business entertainment edutainment
whatever kind of thing and I think
people are realizing now that that's
kind of a limited way of do of living of
having social media maybe in the future
because it's really easy to get people
together to communicate through Twitter
and through Facebook if it was done
correctly or another entity that will do
it better to be able to bring people
together to really talk about stuff sure
maybe it doesn't require digital media
maybe it requires an in-person medium of
some sort we have these guys called to
connect guys that go around making peace
around the world by doing something as
simple as you know you put your head
yeah let's go hold on bullets yeah and
then they go mmm
and you would do it too and so then
that's supposed to you know bond people
together in that sense as well so it
might not be even though digital is
important and it can get to seven and a
half billion people really quickly
you're saying some sometimes it you can
feel art it could feel superficial but
given the importance of the situation it
can bring people together if the if what
they're really rallying about is
important you feel it yeah let's ask you
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world
sunrise mmm-hmm
why because every time I see the sunrise
I realized that there is still life that
is living and it's a new day and things
can change for the better
yeah that's good I like that it's very
inspirational the sunrises and sunsets
have been an answer on the show before
and we totally love both of that both of
them but also the thought that maybe we
can do it better maybe we can make this
day better and keep making it better for
our kids down the line Wow
that it's so tough to unpack all this
information we just because you're mean
you're dealing with so many different
clients and the clients like oh how do I
apply this really future technology to
my business and then you're like well
there's probably a couple dozen ways to
do that but let me tell you about the
one or two or three ways that's most
applicable to you and then they're like
how do I apply it all twelve of these
technologies to my business and you're
like wow good luck like I guess I can
help you but it'll be really difficult
it's just this was happening with these
exponential technologies yeah I think
the biggest question most people have is
what does this all mean and where do I
end up with it and what's the answer to
that
I think the experience is what really
counts and when people are living their
lives how they experience things on a
personal level yes a huge difference
what your what's happening with these
new technologies it brings you closer to
a real-life experience where you
actually live through it and feel it
almost instantaneously yeah if it's done
correctly yeah exactly the the notion of
people remembering their experiences and
how something made them feel yeah yeah
this crucial so if one thing's taken
away for businesses that are tuning in
right now are people that own businesses
just that I'd that idea of creating an
experience or feeling for people that
long-lasting that they'll want to share
with other people that's how we can
leverage all these technologies that
we've been talking about trying to make
that impact on people arena thank you so
much for joining us thank you this has
been such a pleasure thank you thank you
hate talking to you yeah hopefully we'll
continue exchanging awesome people and
networks and impact I already know that
there's so many people to push over to
transformation group as as they're
trying to figure out how to how to bring
these technologies into the future and
help guide other businesses on how to do
that thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate it
make sure to subscribe to the channel
give us a comment below with your
thoughts share the content with other
people to get them talking about what
autonomous vehicles and arv are and
robotics and and chatbots and all this
crazy technologies gonna be doing in the
future the little little human head at
home that you come to then you say hi
and it just says hi back to you what's
that gonna be like what's that gonna be
like for your kids let's keep talking
about this thanks to Ron or producing
partner for producing the show thanks
everyone
join us on patreon when you sustain the
studio need to sustain our project so
join us on patreon please and we'll see
you guys more soon thank you
[Music]
[Music]